[Musik]
großrzier im Frankfurter bahnhofsfittel
von allen Seiten rückt die Polizei vor
die Straße wird komplett abgeriegelt
rund 200 Beamte sind im Einsatz vorbei
an Drogensüchtigen die benebelt auf dem
Gehweg liegen haben sie es auf
Drogendealer abgesehen über ein Dutzend
Personen werden
festgesetzt manche versuchen sich zu
widersetzen es ist bereits das dritte
Mal innerhalb weniger Wochen dass die
Frankfurter Polizei
zugreift Ergänzung zu unseren
schwerpunktmaßnahmen die wir bereits
seit September letzten Jahres fahren wir
hatten eine Kriminalitätsentwicklung im
Spätsommer letzten Jahres die uns auch
ein bisschen Sorge bereitet hat wir
haben massiven Anstieg im Bereich
raubdelektetasen und rbstelle hier im
Bereich des bahnhofsgebietes haben
darauf mit einer deutlichen Erhöhung der
polizilichen Präsenz jeden Tag reagiert
und flankierend zu dieser Erhöhung der
Präsenz machen wir auch Anlass
unabhängig immer mal wieder solche
großkontrollen gemeinsam mit der
Bereitschaftspolizei zusammen die
Personalien werden aufgenommen
durchsucht Drogen sichergestellt im
bahnhofsfittel ist die Polizei jeden Tag
mit mehr Einsatzkräften unterwegs als in
allen anderen Bezirken der Stadt ren wie
diese erhöhen zusätzlich den Druck es
konzentriert sich auf die Örtlichkeiten
wo die beschwerdelage am höchsten ist
und wo nach polizeilichen
Erfahrungswerten Straftaten verabredet
oder begangen werden und es führt dazu
dass wir Straftäter aus Anonymität holen
die Szene
verunsichern und im besten Fall
verbotene Substanzen Gegenstände
Auffinden sicherstellen können und
Strafverfahren ein
Rotlichtbezirk Partymeile und
drogenhotspot hier im Frankfurter
bahnhofsvtel prallen die Milieus
aufeinander das Elend der abhängigen ist
überall im Straßenbild sichtbar sie
sitzen auf den Gehwegen und den
Hauseingängen konsumieren offen ihre
Drogen es wird gedealt manche sind
vollkommen
weggetreten am Straßenrand sitzt Manuel
er kommt aus der Nähe von Wetzler schon
als Jugendlicher hat er das
bahnhosfittel und seine Anziehungskraft
kennengelernt
war jetzt aber schon länger nicht mehr
hier erzählt er ja ich woll es mal
ausprobieren anschauen ich w mal
Eindruck verschaffen weil ich bekannte
gesucht
habe die wieder hier ist in diesem
Viertel seine bekannte findet er aber
sie ist kaum ansprechbar wie es hier im
Viertel mittlerweile aussieht schockiert
ihn selbst dabei hat auch er schon lange
mit seiner Sucht zu
kämpfen mittlerweile bin
ich sich hab 50 Entgiftung wegen Alkohol
hinter mir zwei
Therapien se s mal Kokain gezogen auch
mit ametaminkontakt gehabt und
existier
aber was ich hier jetzt sehe und lebe
mit fetü und so
weiter Crack und Heroin das
ist hässlich geworden richtig
hässlich richtig hässlich war es früher
schon einmal 30 Jahre zurück Anfang der
90er gab es in Frankfurt eine der
größten offenen Drogenszenen Europas in
der taunosanlage einem Grünstreifen
inmitten der Bürotürme lebten bis zu
1500 Süchtige Heroin überschwemmte die
Stadt die Polizei bekam die Lage nicht
in den Griff die Geburtsstunde des
sogenannten Frankfurter Wegs
Drogensüchtige werden seitdem nicht mehr
als Kriminelle gesehen sondern mit
Hilfsangeboten unterstützt Visier stehen
die Dealer damals absolutes Neuland
lange Zeit eine Erfolgsgeschichte die
Zahl der Drogentoten pro Jahr ist
seitdem deutlich
gesunken war es früher Heroin dominiert
heute Crack es macht die Menschen
schneller physisch und psychisch kaputt
Wolfgang Bart ist seit 40 Jahren in der
Drogenhilfe aktiv leitet den
drogennotdienst mit einem von vier
konsumräumen im bahnhusfittel die
Fixerstuben neben Druck von der Straße
hier können sich abhängige unter
kontrollierten Bedingungen
heruinspritzen in einem Notfall kann
geschultes Personal sofort eingreifen
und helfen wir müssen uns aber auch
darauf einstellen dass andere
konsummuste dazu geführt haben dass
Personen ein anderes Verhalten zeigen
die wir mit den bestehenden
Hilfeangeboten nicht erreichen können
und damit meine ich das Thema Crack das
Thema crack ist für uns das größte
Problem dass wir hier neben dem
unkontrollierten Alkoholkonsum
absolut als das vorrangig zu lösende im
Moment hier sehen die Wirkung von Heroin
hält wesentlich länger an bei Crack das
eigentlich Kokain in Form von kleinen
Steinchen ist und geraucht wird sind es
nur wenige
Minuten das berauschende Gefühl ist
dabei so stark dass die Süchtigen sich
gleich wieder auf die Suche nach dem
nächsten Kick
machen wir hatten bis in die 90er Jahre
hinein lange gefordert dass wir ein weit
ausgebautes differenziertes
hilfeprogramm in erster Linie für
Heroinabhängige schaffen mussten das ist
auch umgesetzt worden wir konnten nicht
zu dem Zeitpunkt damals damit rechnen
dass es hier eine Welle gibt an greck
das hier in Frankfurt und das gibt es in
Deutschland vergleichbar nur noch in
Hamburg so auf den Markt kommt und in
einer solchen Dominanz dann auch
das Konsumverhalten der Betroffenen
verändert und bestimmt das Viertel
versinkt teilweise in unerträglichem
Dreck oft riecht es beißend nach Urin
immer wieder liegen benutzte spritzen
und andere Hinterlassenschaften auf den
Gehwegen kein anderes Stadtgebiet ist
dermaßen vermüllt ecoooter kreuz und
quer auf den Gehwegen Mülltonnen werden
auf der Suche nach verwertbarem
umgestoßen und durchwühlt Überreste der
vergangenen Partynacht aller Orten die
Stadtreinigung ist 7 Tage in der Woche
intensiv im Einsatz mit kehmaschinen und
Handbesen mehrmal am Tag säubern die
Mitarbeiter das Viertel doch so schnell
wie der Dreck auftaucht kann er nicht
entsorgt
werden wir haben inzwischen vier
Schichten im
Einsatz und wir machen jeden Morgen auch
eine intensive
flächenreinigung das bedeutet dass wir
wirklich auch mitm Wasserwagen aus
hygienischen Gründen gewisse Straßen
reinigen und im Vergleich zumb zur Zeil
sind wir hier wesentlich öfter und
intensiver im Einsatz die Vermüllung
trübt das ganze B abstoßen für Pendler
Touristen Kunden und Geschäftsinhaber
und eigentlich nicht in den Griff zu
bekommen im theoretischen Fall bekommen
wir alles sauber das ist im Endeffekt
ein Einsatz von Ressourcen den müssen
wir Abwegen mit der
Wirtschaftlichkeit und man muss es halt
aber auch ins Verhältnis stellen also es
ist sicherlich nicht angemessen 24
Stunden überall permanent sauber zu
halten und zu reinigen das würde
natürlich komplett die
Wirtschaftlichkeit sprengen ja zum
Schluss muss es jemand bezahlen z.B die
Marktbetreiber und Geschäftsinhaber doch
für viele wird die Lage immer
schwieriger nach Corona sind Kunden
nicht zurückgekommen sie bleiben im
Homeoffice andere lassen sich durch die
offene Drogenszene und die gestiegene
Kriminalität abschrecken das Aus für
viele Betriebe der Gemüsehändler ist an
diesem Tag zum letzten Mal an diesem
Standort es lohnt sich nicht mehr das
ist das Problem was wir hier seit
ungefähr einhalb Jahren wirklich extrem
haben gerade die die Läden die so
tagsüber hier hier sind oder auch die
Restaurants dass die ganz massiv klagen
dass sich das Publikum total verändert
hat
Ulrich Mattner kennt das bnosfittel aus
dem FF er wohnt hier seit 14 Jahren
mittendrin eine Zeitlang war
Vorsitzender des Gewerbevereins Müll
junkys Bettler Obdachlose Kriminalität
die Situation für Gewerbetreibende ist
denkbar schlecht dennoch kommt von ihnen
öffentlich meist nur verhaltene
Kritik da musst du sehr vorsichtig sein
weil du dann von den Gewerbetreibenden
gesagt bekommst von vielen du schadest
unserem Viertel du machst das unser
Viertel noch schlimmer und das ist ein
Grund die überlegen sich wirklich zehn
Malal ob sie vor die Kamera gehen oder
nicht weil sie ja dann quasi gerade die
Hoteliers äh ihrem eigenen rufschaden ja
und vielleicht Großkunden die da 20 30
Zimmer wie eine Airline buchen dann
vielleicht abspringen die Schuhmacherei
Lenz eines der letzten
Traditionsgeschäfte mit über 80 Jahren
Geschichte inmitten der Restaurants
Supermärkte Friseursalons und Bars
betreibt Alexander do zusammen mit
seinem Vater den Betrieb in fünfter
Generation er hat schon viele Geschäfte
kommen und gehen sehen die Veränderungen
im Viertel bereiten auch ihm Sorgen da
fängt man natürlich auch selbst drüber
nachzudenken was passiert dort geht's
mir ähnlich bin ich dann auch irgendwann
mal so einer der dann sein Schaufenster
abhängt und seine Sachen packt ja es ist
halt so ein bisschen das Ungewisse und
ich glaub glaub ich ZRE einfach davon
dass es wirklich was Außergewöhnliches
ist was ich mache wo die Leute dann auch
sagen ich möchte hierher kommmen weil
ich gute Arbeit ma und dann nehme ich
auch einfach den Weg ins Bahnhofsviertel
auf mich ja die kommen dann gezielt
hierher die gehen dann auch gezielt
wieder raus sein Ziel ist hier auch noch
die nächsten 35 oder 40 Jahre zu bleiben
und sein Schuhmacherhandwerk zu
betreiben ich lieb das Viertel definitiv
sonst wird es mich nicht so lange hier
halten das Miteinander von den
Geschäftstreibenden ja das ist einfach
schön ja man kennt sich die Leute die
hier schon länger sind da wird gegrüßt
da wird ein Schwätzchen gehalten und das
ist halt einfach dieses Multikulti was
mir auch unheimlich gefällt und dieses
große miteinander das das macht schon
viel Scharm aus hier im
warnel auch Ulrich Mattner lebt gern
hier doch die Drogenpolitik der Stadt
könne so nicht weitergehen es werde
immer viel geredet aber wenig
getan
seit 25 Jahren kannst du sagen pendelt
die Zahl der Drogentoten zwischen 20 und
40 so immer hin und her ja und daran
siehst du dass das konstant wird das
verwaltet wird viel Geld ausgegeben aber
an sich wird nicht mehr weiter da dran
gearbeitet einfach dass man wieder
modernere Wege findet denen zu helfen
und die aus diesem Schicksal zu
befreien die Polizei reagiert mit mehr
Präsenz und ren sie mischt die Szene der
Drogendealer immer wieder auf bei den
Maßnahmen an diesem Tag werden acht
Personen festgenommen wegen
Drogenhandels insgesamt 20
Ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet rund 30
g Crack
beschlagnahmt doch der Erfolg ist nur
von kurzer Dauer und noch mehr
polizeiansätze lassen die Kapazitäten
kaum
zu mit vollzugspolizeilichen Maßnahmen
alleine wird man diese Problemlage hier
hier nicht in den Griff bekommen da ist
es zwingend notwendig dass alle
Sicherheitspartner gemeinsam an einem
Strang ziehen und dann am besten auch
noch in die gleiche
Richtung der Magistrat der Stadt gerät
zunehmend unter Druck als Sofortmaßnahme
gibt es erst einmal Geld 5 Millionen
Euro stellt die Regierungskoalition im
Römer bereit unter anderem für mehr
Betreuungsplätze und Tagesbetten der
Oberbürgermeister hat bei seinem
Amtsantritt im Frühjahr das Thema
bahnosfittel ganz oben auf seine Agenda
gesetzt jetzt macht er ernst
per Verordnung Gegenteile seiner eigenen
Regierungskoalition wird zum 1 November
eine waffenverbotszone eingeführt jedes
Messer weniger dient dem Opferschutz und
kann eine potenzielle Gewalttat
verhindern deswegen ist jedes Messer
jede Waffe weniger an der Stelle erstmal
gut und deswegen haben wir die
waffenverbotszone eingerichtet bei den
Videoüberwachung ist es ähnlich bin
jetzt seit 5 Monaten Oberbürgermeister
ich habe gute Gespräche geführt mit der
sicherheitsdezinentin mit dem
Polizeipräsidium das ist jetzt auf dem
Weg gebracht worden bis Ende Januar
steht das ganze dann sollen zusätzliche
Kameras installiert sein richtige und
längst überfällige Maßnahmen sagt die
Gewerkschaft der Polizei sie fordert das
schon seit Jahren in wiesbahn ist es
bereits seit über vier Jahren verboten
im Bereich der Innenstadt Waffen mitit
sich zu tragen in anderen deutschen
Städten ebenfalls die Ergebnisse
durchaus positiv nur in Frankfurt
bislang nicht
durchsetzbar der Vorteil ist natürlich
es passieren die meisten Straftaten im
übrigen mit Messern oder gefährlich
Gegenständen dass diese Gegenstände eben
nicht mehr
bei den entsprechenden Personen
mitgeführt werden und wir eine
Kontrollinstanz als Polizei haben und
solche Gegenstände aus Verkehr ziehen
können für viele ein Schritt in die
richtige Richtung es wird aber noch
etliche weitere Schritte brauchen um das
bahnhusfittel wieder sicherer und
lebenswerter zu machen es ist die
Neujustierung des Frankfurter Wegs Hilfe
für die drogenkranken Härte gegen die
Dealer zusätzlich brauche das ganze
Gebiet einen teilweisen Umbau da ist
sich Wolfgang Bart
sicher es muss hier Wohnraum geben der
auch zur Verfügung gestellt wird für
Geringverdiener für junge Familien für
Wohngemeinschaften wenn dieses diese
Attraktivität geschaffen wird dann wird
es aus meinem Verständnis heraus auch zu
einer gewissen Verdrängung derjenigen
geben kommen die sich jetzt noch in der
Öffentlichkeit Delinquent Verhalten die
sehen dass sie untertauchen können in
großen Gruppierungen in denen sie dann
nicht mehr auffallen wenn dieses durch
eine Beruhigung in dem Stadtviertel
verhindert werden kann dann werden wir
auf dem richtigen Weg sicher kein
leichter Weg im Grunde sind sich alle
Beteiligten einig das etwas und auch was
geschehen muss mit der Einführung einer
waffenverbotszone ist ein Anfang gemacht
jetzt müssen weitere Maßnahmen nur
konsequent umgesetzt werden denn das
Frankfurter bahnhofsvittel bleibt
Anziehungspunkt für unterschiedlichste
Menschen und damit auch ein
Brennpunkt